hey everyone welcome to the uplift we've
got a great show for you a great cast of
characters as well and as always and we
are going to begin with a pediatric
surgeon who goes the extra mile for
young patients even before they enter
the operating room look at this guy also
a resilient ballerina many of them in
fact in Ukraine who are still dancing
despite the war and a basketball player
who is a star on the court but also a
role model but he's not on the court and
a bus driver who became a hero for a
child with autism what he did to save
this little boy's life we'll get into it
plus meet a man known as an honorary
citizen of Disneyland what he did to
earn the title we'll explain find out
coming up you're watching The Uplift
[Music]
hey there I'm Tony decopo this is the
uplift the show that lifts you up for at
least the next 30 minutes you and me as
well and we're going to begin with that
story about a pediatric surgeon who goes
above and beyond for his young patients
here's Natasha lorno with the story
heading into surgery without their
parents can be scary for kids but
pediatric surgeon Dr Hashem found a way
to ease the anxiety of his young
patients my whole life has been dealing
with children especially the ones who
are in pain in agony in a situation that
is stressful in a way I was searching
all the time for a way that can lessen
down their anxiousness to break the ice
between us to have a pleasant time
before we are put to sleep and going to
surgery Dr Hashem says making the
children smile and entertaining them
before going into surgery has had
tremendous benefits that he hopes have
lasting impacts
the mental and psychological status of a
person can totally alter or change your
perception of pain because it releases
endorphins from within your body so you
can respond differently to Nokia stimuli
or painful conditions I got a lot of
feedbacks from the families saying that
because of this our child has had a good
experience with his surgery we were even
not afraid that they are leaving us at
the red line and going with you to the
or they may be leaving their parents at
the door of the or but they're in good
hands with Dr Hashem
they are in good hands indeed and we're
going to go now to the heartwarming
story a video that shows a mom Ladonna
Lively celebrating birthday number 6-0
and receiving not one not two but three
huge gifts for her Three Sons
my friend just surprised me
did you guys make a reservation or do we
need to
[Music]
[Laughter]
how much are you guys watching
[Applause]
happy birthday
I love how she's still surprised when
the third side shows up like no it's
counting on him the good boys that's so
sweet uh so let me see if we get this
straight her sons flew in uh to
Nashville uh one from California one
from Texas and one from Chicago Illinois
to surprise her one by one uh completely
unannounced they had no uh she had no
idea was coming you could look on her
face she was definitely in total shock
uh each and every time every time low
expectations it's a good result anyway
our next video show is 11 year old
Elijah who received a gift from
Make-a-Wish a gift he had been dreaming
of
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's so cute
oh
before
wow that is really really sweet Elijah
had said he wanted a corgi a corgi
rather and he wanted a corgi named
Tucker in fact and what you're looking
at is him receiving a corgi named Tucker
that's exactly what he got all right
coming up a teen hockey player organized
a grand gesture on the ice for a fellow
classmate and that grand gesture went
viral what was the big surprise we'll
tell you plus meet the kids who are
working on an out of this world you
might say project for a major American
corporation or organization you've
probably heard of it we'll explain
thank you
a group of high school students in Texas
are working on a giant project together
but it's not a project for school in
fact it's a project that is you might
say out of this world here's Olivia Lee
schrer CBS Dallas station with more
it's Monday morning at Ben Barber
innovation academy
these high school students are hard at
work using highly technical machines to
fabricate Parts in this manufacturing
class
but this isn't your ordinary school
project they're working on parts that
will be used by NASA we're building a
component to a storage locker box and
the storage locker box is a uh part that
they use to send supplies or experiments
up to the astronauts at the space
station that's right a mission destined
for the stars that would be really cool
just knowing that we're making a
difference even if it's something as
small as a a lid for a locker these
students are part of NASA 100
177 schools in wide 20 of which are here
in north Texas and we tell them that you
know you guys aren't just a bunch of
high school students that are that are
working on a project you're actually
you're working for NASA you're on the
NASA team as NASA's newest team members
these students traveled to the Johnson
Space Center in Houston to hand deliver
the parts they've built it changes your
perspective from that of Little enclosed
oh that's just the grade what if I fail
to
wow this is going up to the space
station and it's going to help
astronauts store their materials and
their experiments
this is a little bigger than an A plus
in a class students are trained and
mentored by NASA employees and the parts
they make are inspected and held to
NASA's rigorous standards these are not
widgets and these are not paperweights
these are actual structural components
that are flying to the space station
students are are told when a part
they've worked on is included in a NASA
launch and they even get a photo of it
in use in space
for students like Abigail Gibson the
NASA hunch program has helped them
discover new career paths they never
would have considered I feel really
ready for what's going to come after
high school so that's pretty nice and
I'm getting first-hand experience of
what I'm going to do for the rest of my
life
fly rocket fly all right to our next
story a high school hockey player in
Minnesota recently decided to shoot his
shot before a game here's Marielle Mose
with his story
number seven Alexander the lineup
announcement ahead of boys state hockey
games is usually an opportunity for
players to wave to their friends and
family
this message wasn't for Mom and Dad the
blade on his stick reads hey Sarah prom
didn't know what to think I was super
shocked Sarah stagena facetimed us from
Laverne back home after the team fell to
Hermantown on Wednesday the team may
have lost but she still feels like she
picked up a win it really it made me
happy that he was so bold with it and
just went for it I didn't really want to
say it because obviously if she's at the
game so she can't hear it over the
Jumbotron so it kind of had to be
spelled out or else she wouldn't have
known what I said she of course said yes
but being asked to prom wasn't the only
surprise when I got back everybody in
the locker room was saying oh you're
going viral already the fast Fame wasn't
Brady's Focus he just wanted to soak in
these last moments as a senior playing
hockey and making his family proud
the LaVerne boys ended their run in the
consolation bracket on Thursday but
Brady did get a goal a prom date and a
lot of hype online maybe I'll go look on
Twitter and make myself feel a little
bit better
that's lovely all right from Sports to
sports coming up no matter how the NCAA
tournament turns out this college
basketball player is already a winner
because of what he does off the court
Plus in Ukraine these ballerinas
continue to dance in spite of the war
and they are sending a powerful message
just by taking the stage
I mean I think a lot of people back home
when I came they asked me if Kiev was
destroyed and I said absolutely not you
know it's it's not destroyed and to
continue on is really the Ukrainian
spirit it's really incredible to see
that
people continuing to just not exist but
live
[Applause]
we're going to introduce you now to a
college basketball star making a name
for himself off the court as a role
model here's Nancy Chen with the story
Cliff amori is known for his Powerhouse
ducks
but the Rutgers University Junior only
started playing basketball at 14 just
before his family in Nigeria sent him to
New Jersey it was just like to get a
better education amore
with the basketball program at Salvation
Army
Army to play basketball what did you
think am I being honest there oh yeah he
had a lot of work we had to basically
start from scratch Oliver was not only
Amore's legal guardian but also a
motivator I almost give up on basketball
like he gave me they believe that I
could be what I want to be if I just
keep walking that work ethic applied off
the court too because of cliff my son
improved academically tremendously he
saw a cliff how he handled basketball
and books he was a role model 100 a
great role model actually as one of the
best players in the Big Ten Conference
Amore earned 25
000 from endorsements money he donated
to revitalize the court Where it All
Began honoring his mentor he's changed
her life yeah
I think he's changed our life as well
too though a powerful Athlete on College
basketball's biggest stage
all right we're going to introduce you
now to ballerinas in Ukraine ballerinas
who are still dancing despite the war
and they're doing so to remind people of
their country's culture and its strength
[Music]
they are the front line Ukraine's fight
to preserve its cultural heritage
armed with pirouettes Plies and chites
in a battle of survival for an art form
they've dedicated their lives to
like Olga kifiak Von Kramer La Prima
ballerina at the Ukraine National Ballet
one of the country's most celebrated
performers
Ukraine is still at War you're still
dancing why is it so important to still
dance
we want the world to see that Ukraine
also has its own incredible culture she
says that's why we continue to dance we
dance in spite of Russia
ballet has long been one of moscow's
most revered cultural exports but
several of its most acclaimed answers
were either from or trained in Ukraine
Vladimir Putin launched his invasion one
year ago the curtain went down on stages
across the country leading some
Ukrainian performers to pick up arms and
join the fight including Alexander
shopoval he was the principal dancer at
the Ukraine National Ballet a once in a
generation Talent who over the course of
28 Seasons performed in 30 different
roles
but he will never dance again in
September the 48 year old father of two
was killed in a Russian mortar attack
his funeral was televised on Ukrainian
State TV where he was remembered as a
courageous romantic
for Makita sukaruko shapoval was a
mentor and friend he's now taken over
his role as the company's principal
dancer a role sukurukov feels the weight
of
how did you feel when you learned
Alexander died
um
it was very difficult for I think for
all company it was very difficult it
really brought the war here
back to this company yep
yep
[Music]
but here at the national Opera theater
in Kiev
for a brief moment in time audiences are
transfixed by dazzling performances on
stage
tonight it's the classic Don Quixote a
romantic comedy for the ages with
sukurukov starring in the lead role
a performance attended by American page
VN originally from Seattle she now works
as a volunteer and key so supporting the
arts for you is really an act of
defiance to Russia's aggression yeah I
mean I think a lot of people back home
when I came they asked me if Kiev was
destroyed and I said absolutely not you
know it's it's not destroyed and to
continue on is really the Ukrainian
spirit it's really incredible to see
that
people continuing to just not exist but
live
but so many lives continue to be lost
including kitiak Von Kramer's brother
who died fighting in eastern Ukraine in
August still she says nothing will stop
her from performing
yes it's hard she says but we are
ukrainians we are unbreakable
an unbreakable Spirit on the front lines
and on stage
the show goes on and so does the
Ukrainian spirit it's a beautiful piece
and coming up another one you're going
to be a California Native who loves
Disneyland alive and was recently
recognized for his multi-year nearly
decade long in fact commitment to the
park
plus meet a Minnesota bus driver who
noticed something wrong noticed
something and then sprang into action
something we don't always do he ended up
saving a boy with autism
we taken out of Southern California for
a trip to Disneyland isn't that nice
we're gonna introduce you to a man who's
been going there for a long long time in
fact he's been called the honorary
citizen of that particular theme park
here's Caitlin O'Kane
Jeff writes loves Disneyland a lot to
show you how much he loves the theme
park we need to go back to January 1st
2012. I was at Disneyland with friends
and we were joking around about a
commercial that Disney ran when they
announced the leap day 24 hour event
saying that they were going to be giving
you an extra Disney day and we had joked
around that how could it be an extra day
if you didn't use the others
so we decided to go for all 366 days of
2012. after that year Jeff and a friend
continued to go every single day in
2013. we were both unemployed and we had
annual passes that have been given to us
the previous year as gifts so we decided
to use it as a positive it got you out
of bed and out outside to get some fresh
air
um you know because
it can be depressing when you're out of
work after two years his friend stopped
joining him but Jeff kept going and
after five years Jeff kept going and
after eight years Jeff kept going Disney
has always been something that's full of
magic for a lot of people and there's
always been a lot of different ways to
experience it and you know me going
every day was just my way that I enjoyed
going to Disneyland for that period when
he got a full-time job job Jeff had a
lot to juggle but fortunately he lives
nearby the park and would drive there
each evening practicing his photography
getting some steps in or sometimes
seeing attractions like his favorite
Star Wars
March 14 2020 was the date of his
2995th visit and it was his last
Disneyland temporarily closed its doors
due to the covid-19 pandemic his streak
was over I am outside the gate
not sure when I'll be back but wanted to
get this moment I was disappointed
because it had been a lot of fun and the
idea of it coming to an end was a little
was a little sad but on the other side I
was also happy in the sense of how
things ended because I was still happy
and healthy and you know my family was
healthy so it's not like something
happened as a catastrophe where I wasn't
able to go because of something that
happened to me Jeff became a bit of a
celebrity during his eight years at the
park and he made many friends along the
way but he hasn't been back to
Disneyland since it reopened in 2020
still those past visits were not taken
in vain he was recently contacted by
Guinness World Records you know the
frosting on the cake was I had never
actually filed with Guinness for the
record they contacted me they sent me a
question and answer form to fill out and
at the top it said congratulations are
your new record
so I was like um should I be film this
out I never actually filed for a record
that's how Jeff was told Guinness had
recognized his eight years three months
and 13 days at the park naming him the
world record holder for most consecutive
trips to Disneyland it added a little
extra magic to all those trips to the
happiest place on earth
oh my God I love that story I don't
think that record is ever going to fall
congratulations to him
all right to our next story a bus driver
working during the snowstorm in
Minnesota recently became a hero to a
young boy with autism
here CBS Minnesota's Kirsten Mitchell
she's got the story
we're definitely eyes and ears we're
trained that way just four months on the
job as a Metro Transit bus operator we
helped as many people as we can Ambrose
young proved driving is more than
getting from point A to B
February 22nd a winter storm canceled
School young was on his route near
Theodore worth park in Minneapolis I saw
this child walking and to myself I was
like that's pretty weird the
nine-year-old boy was wearing a backpack
walking alone in the cold men trying to
get into a car you just knew something
was off absolutely
young pulled over and got the child on
board the warm bus he noticed he was
non-verbal and anxious later learning he
had autism the boy had walked about 15
blocks from his home to where driver
Young found him the high temperature
that day was just 21 degrees the child
matched the description of a boy who had
wandered off we held hands out of the
bus metro transit patrol officer Juan
Peralta helped reunite him with his
family this was a very caring loving
family that just one of their kid backed
do you feel like a hero no being a dad
I'm very happy that I was able to step
in you know and help this child you know
I would hope that someone does that for
my children as well whether you know
they were victims of a crime and they're
having a medical emergency
the street is safer because of these bus
drivers I'm just happy he was able to
get safely back to his family
hey that's a great piece and that is our
show I hope it brightened your day I
hope it lifted you up I'm confident it
did if it didn't for some reason reruns
are free I'm gonna go find some more
good news